die golden gate bridge das wahrzeichen
san francisco
die wohl am meisten fotografierte brücke
der welt
ihre konstruktion ein technisches
meisterwerk
eine derart große brücke über dem
offenen meer zu bauen mitten im
erdbebengebiet ein unvorstellbares
wagnis
sie ist eine berühmtheit unter den
brücken elegant überspannt die golden
gate bridge seit 1937 den eingang zur
bucht von san francisco
im vergleich dazu eine ikone der neuzeit
die golden gate bridge in den usa versus
das viadukt von mio in frankreich eine
brücke der superlative höher als der
eiffelturm länger als die champs élysées
und ihr anblick absolut beeindruckend es
ist erstaunlich wie so ein koloss
dennoch grazil und fast schwerelos
wirken kann es scheint als schwebe die
brücke über den wolken
das viadukt von mio auf französisch
viadukte mio ist wie die golden gate
bridge ein meisterwerk der architektur
beide brücken sind ikonen von millionen
menschen bewundert was haben sie
gemeinsam was unterscheidet sie wir
vergleichen in drei kategorien
design
welche bahnbrechende ideen stecken in
diesen drücken
[Musik]
wow
wie schwer ist es die giganten zu
errichten
und effizienz
wie schlagen sich die brücken in der
praxis
[Musik]
san francisco 1 die stadt der goldsucher
und hippies heute eine der bedeutsamsten
standorte der tech industrie doch
berühmt ist die kalifornische metropole
auch für die golden gate bridge im mai
1937 wurde sie feierlich eröffnet
mit einer spannweite von
1280 metern hält sie fast drei
jahrzehnte den rekord als längste
hängebrücke der welt
ihre türme ragen
227 meter über die wasseroberfläche die
golden gate bridge ist gigantisch
[Musik]
hier deckt hängt an zwei haupt kabeln es
sind die dicksten und längsten
kabelstränge der welt
rund 80.000 tonnen stahl stecken in dem
koloss das gesamtgewicht rund 900.000
tonnen all das gebaut in gerade mal vier
jahren eine revolution in der geschichte
der brücken architektur
es war nicht ein rekord es waren gleich
mehrere eigentlich war alles an der
golden gate eine sensation
doch wie schlägt sich die über 80
jährige ikone im vergleich mit der
modernen brücke vom mio die viel später
gebaut wurde
im dezember 2004 wird die vom britischen
architekten norman foster designte
brücke im süden frankreichs eingeweiht
[Musik]
das viadukt von mio
mit einer gesamtlänge von
2.460 metern die längste
schrägseilbrücke der welt
sie ist über 340 meter hoch und zählt zu
den höchsten brücken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
154 seile befestigt an sieben pylonen
tragen dass brücken deck insgesamt
stecken mehr als
36.000 tonnen stahl und
200.000 tonnen beton im viadukt von mio
die bauzeit gerade einmal drei jahre
beide brücken gehören auf jeden fall zu
den großartigsten konstruktionen der
welt welche beeindruckende ist wir
werden sie
die golden gate bridge und das viadukt
von mio zweibrücken der superlative
erste hauptkategorie design
welche technischen innovationen stecken
in den rücken
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts san
francisco platzt aus allen nähten
das problem die stadt liegt auf einer
halbinsel neuer wohnraum ist deshalb
ebenso begehrt wie knapp kaum eine
andere amerikanische stadt wuchs damals
so schnell und hatte gleichzeitig so
wenig platz sich auszudehnen
im norden liegen die dhünn bewohnten
gebiete des marin county durch die
meerenge golden gate genannt von der
stadt getrennt um neuen wohnraum für die
bewohner san francisco zu schaffen muss
eine brücke her
doch das scheint hier unmöglich zu sein
eine gruppe mutiger ingenieure wagt es
dennoch
ihre größte herausforderung die enorme
spannweite denn die meerenge ist
eineinhalb kilometer breit und das
wasser tief und tückisch
die einzige möglichkeit der ingenieure
eine hängebrücke denn sie müssen die
anzahl der pfeiler möglichst gering
halten um nicht den regen schiffsverkehr
zu beeinträchtigen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit hängebrücken lassen sich große
spannweiten überwinden doch in dieser
dimension hat er das noch keiner gewagt
ob das bei einer spannweite von über
einem kilometer funktioniert was damals
keiner
der entwurf geht als radikal und beruht
auf einer modernen theorie
rücken mit extremer spannweite sollen
durch ihr höheres gewicht selbst
stabilisierend wirken sie sind dabei
nicht starr sondern schwingen im wind
und sinken bei belastung ab die
ingenieure benötigen so weniger
versteifung elemente unterhalb des
brücken decks von sparen auch noch
kosten engel seilbrücken müssen
sozusagen gleichzeitig stabil und
flexibel sein im rahmen genau
festgelegter grenzen sonst droht ein
kollaps
[Musik]
kalkül edding immer so richtig
aufeinander abzustimmen so unglaublich
kompliziert dass die statischen analyse
füllten zehneinhalb ende alles berechnet
ohne computer
die golden gate bridge schwingt bis zu
acht meter im wind bei voller last sinkt
das deck ganze fünf meter ab nur so ist
es überhaupt möglich die damals längste
hängebrücke der welt zu bauen eine
gratwanderung bei der jedes detail
entscheidet ob sie wirklich hält
[Musik]
der entwurf ebenso innovativ wie gewagt
wie mutig sind die französischen
ingenieure
die beeindruckenden schluchten des
flusses tagen im süden frankreichs sind
hunderte meter tief
und die karge landschaft besteht
vorwiegend aus kalkstein nicht gerade
die besten voraussetzungen für eine
brücke
die teller sind ein nadelöhr für den
europäischen fernverkehr
besonders in urlaubszeiten kommt es zu
staus und unfällen über 20 jahre
untersuchen experten die gegend um
dieses problem zu bewältigen
[Musik]
die lösung eine schrägseilbrücke bei der
die seile direkt von den pylonen zum
brücken deck führen
aber dieser neuere brücken typ ist noch
nie in einer solchen dimension gebaut
worden
sie reicht von anhöhe zu an höhe und hat
eine gesamtlänge von zweieinhalb
kilometern
als ingenieur miguel veloso zum ersten
mal seine pläne vorstellte dachten alle
er sei verrückt
die sieben brückenpfeiler samt pylonen
sind so hoch wie wolkenkratzer bis zu
300 43 meter das problem die pfeiler
müssen einerseits sehr breit und steif
sein um den enormen kräften stand zu
halten die auf sie wirken doch das
brücken deck dehnt sich bei hitze um
mehr als einen halben meter aus
deshalb müssen die pfeiler andererseits
auch flexibel genug sein diese
ausdehnung mitzugehen
die geniale lösung sie teilen sich am
oberen ende hüppes i lon förmlich auf so
sind sie unten steif
und oben flexibel
die pfeiler erinnern an eine stimmgabel
diese form ist technisch wie ästhetisch
genial
nach diesen innovativen plänen bauen die
architekten und ingenieure die längste
schrägseilbrücke der welt
die bauarbeiter brücken gehen neue wege
dank mutiger theorien und überraschender
kniffe setzen sie standards beim
brückenbau
doch das ist nicht alles schließlich
will keiner einen hässlichen rücken
klopps als wahrzeichen
es klingt unglaublich aber der erste
entwurf für die golden gate bridge war
in sachen ästhetik eine absolute
katastrophe
diese kombination aushänge und ausleger
brücke ist nämlich gelinde gesagt alles
andere als elegant
chefingenieur cent auf 1 stahl monster
die menschen empfanden den entwurf
hässlich und deprimierend doch zum glück
hat der beratender ingenieur leon neues
schiff eine völlig andere vision er
reduziert die versteifung elemente auf
ein minimum dadurch wirkt der neue
entwurf schlank und elegant
zusammen mit architekt irving moreau
villa aus der golden gate bridge die
größte art déco skulptur der welt machen
artdeco das ist die vorherrschende es
die richtung der wilden 1920 er die
wirtschaft der siegermächte nach dem
ersten weltkrieg boomt die menschen
glauben an eine bessere zukunft durch
technischen fortschritt
von paris ausgehend erobert art déco die
welt und prägt auch die architektur
amerikanischer großstädte
elegante formen mit klarer geometrie
kostbare materialien sinnliche elemente
und starke farben prägen den stil die
typischen ornamente bögen stufen winkel
und gezackten linien
nach diesem vorbild entsteht der finale
entwurf der golden gate bridge
das design hat dafür gesorgt dass die
golden gate bis heute eine echte legende
ist
moreau designt vor allem die
proportionen und die form der türme neu
wie leitern ragen sie in den himmel
horizontale verstrebungen der türme
deckt er mit sogenannten chef ron
verkleidungen ab so entsteht die größte
art déco brücke der welt
um die fußgängerwege bei dunkelheit zu
beleuchten welt moreau natriumdampf
niederdruck lampen die ein sanftes
bernstein farbenes licht ausstrahlen
nach oben gerichtete lampen sollen die
höhe der brücken türme ins rechte licht
setzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bleibt noch eine frage offen und die
teilt die gemüter welche farbe soll die
brücke erhalten
es gab damals eine riesige diskussion
manche wollten grau damit die golden
gate bridge möglichst wenig heraus
sticht die neben gegen wollte dass die
brücke besonders sichtbar ist wegen tief
fliegender flugzeuge
aus heutiger sicht unfassbar aber die
navy will die golden gate bridge
tatsächlich schwarz gelb streichen
glücklicherweise setzt sich moreau durch
und lässt die brücke in international
ohren streichen einer rostschutz farbe
[Musik]
die farbe greift den er ton der
landschaft auf und bildet gleichzeitig
einen genialen kontrast zum blau des
himmels und des meeres
der name der berühmten brücke kommt
nicht von ihrer farbe sondern von der
meerenge über die sie thront
golden gate zu deutsch goldenes tor
in südfrankreich spannt sich das viadukt
von millau über ein tiefes tal für den
stararchitekten sir norman foster eine
große herausforderung
sein zu dass die aduc familie soll trotz
seiner größe zart und transparent wie
ein schmetterling sein
schrägseilbrücke sind schlanker und
eleganter als andere brücken arten und
da die brückenpfeiler extrem stabil sind
kann das deck besonders flach sein
[Musik]
wenn man die größe des bauwerks bedenkt
ist es tatsächlich erstaunlich wie
filigranes wirkt
zusätzlich setzt foster auf
größtmögliche symmetrie die y form wäre
eigentlich nur bei den äußeren pfeilern
wichtig für die statik der architekt
besteht darauf dass alle so aussehen
oberhalb des brücken decks greift das
design dann die zweigeteilte form der
pfeiler auf und stellt sie sozusagen auf
den kopf dadurch wirken pfeiler und
pylone wie eine einheit die brücke ist
so hoch wie ein wolkenkratzer und wird
gleichzeitig so schmal wie der mast
eines segelschiffs
die beleuchtung unterstreicht diesen
clou in sachen konstruktion pfeiler und
pylonen sollen wie gespiegelt wirken
bei der farbwahl setzt architekt foster
auf helle töne die brücke soll mit dem
himmel verschmelzen transparent wie
schwerelos wirken
er wollte eine brücke so grazil wie
möglich und das ist ihm gelungen das
viadukt von millau ist eine der
leichtesten und schlanksten brücken der
welt
ob anwohner reisende oder
internationales fachpublikum
alle sind vom design begeistert
sowohl die golden gate bridge als auch
das viadukt von mio sind ästhetische
meister werke die sich perfekt in die
landschaft einfügen
wichtiger als schönheit die stabilität
wie effektiv trotzen die brücken designs
die naturgewalten beim bau der golden
gate bridge ein faktor der über leben
und tod entscheidet
denn die san-andreas-verwerfung ist
gerade mal elf kilometer entfernt hier
treffen die pazifische und
nordamerikanische platte aufeinander es
kann jederzeit zu schweren erdbeben
kommen
für die menschen in kalifornien stellt
sich nicht die frage ob sondern wann ist
das nächste große beben geben wird
das bereitet den ingenieuren der golden
gate bridge kopfzerbrechen
ihre brücke muss schweren beben
standhalten
besonders gefährdet die beiden
auffahrten hier werden riesige
verankerungen jeweils 60.000 tonnen
schwer gebaut eine frisch patentierte
innovation soll außerdem vor der
katastrophe schützen
die träger der brücken türme haben eine
wabenstruktur
die soll sie gleichzeitig leicht und
stabil machen
lange zeit glaubte man die golden gate
bridge können dank dieser maßnahmen
beben jeder stärke aushalten aber keiner
wusste genau
jahre vergehen die erde bebt immer
wieder aber nur in geringerem ausmaß
während san francisco jahr für jahr bank
geschieht mehr als 1000 kilometer weiter
nördlich eine katastrophe dieter gohmann
narrows bridge ist mit 850 metern
spannweite die damals drittlängste
brücke der welt aber kurz nach ihrer
eröffnung 1940 muss sie geschlossen
werden und wenige monate später
kollabiert die brandneue brücke ein
mäßig starker wind durch die katastrophe
aus der grund ihre filigrane
konstruktion zum glück kommt kein mensch
ums leben
[Musik]
die elegante form ist er hatte coma
narrows bridge zum verhängnis geworden
durch ihre proportionen die mangelnde
versteifung und eine aerodynamik
ungünstige form war sie extrem flexibel
und anfällig für gefährliche ver
drehbewegungen
der erbauer dieser unglücks brücke heißt
leon neuss er ist auch einer der
federführenden ingenieure der golden
gate bridge
um auf nummer sicher zu gehen versteifen
sie nach dem desaster das brücken deck
der golden gate bridge dies sollen sie
vor starkem wind schützen doch wie steht
es um die erdbebensicherheit der
härtetest steht noch bevor am 17 oktober
1989 ist es soweit 15 sekunden blieb die
erde rund um san francisco heftig und
verursacht schäden in millionenhöhe
63 menschen sterben
nur wenige kilometer entfernt von der
golden gate bridge kollabieren teile der
bay bridge sie ist auch eine hängebrücke
fast zur selben zeit erbaut
die golden gate bridge kommt unbeschadet
davon aber wird sie auch dem nächsten
schweren beben trotzen können der weg
wann kommt bestimmt
bei diesem erdbeben war das epizentrum
mit 100 kilometern relativ weit weg was
wenn das nächste beben ein näheres
epizentrum hat
die ergebnisse wissenschaftlicher
simulationen sind beunruhigend ein
einsturz scheint bei einem stärkeren
leben tatsächlich möglich
mit hilfe von zahlreichen
umbaumaßnahmen und dem einbau von
stoßdämpfern soll die golden gate bridge
noch sicherer werden
letztlich hat dieser umbau bis heute 900
millionen dollar gekostet und ist noch
nicht ganz abgeschlossen
die golden gate bridge hat das bislang
größte erdbeben in ihrer geschichte mit
bravour überstanden
in frankreich muss das viadukt von
millau auch mit naturkatastrophen
rechnen erdbeben sind in dieser region
keine große gefahr die stürmischen winde
hingegen schon
das viadukt familie direkt in der
hauptwindrichtung durch die neue höhe
des brückentags kann die belastung
ziemlich extrem werden
[Musik]
heftige windböen könnten das stählerne
brücken deck schlichtweg in die luft
reißen die ingenieure müssen sich etwas
einfallen lassen die lösung zwischen
pfeilern und brücken deck klafft eine
lücke von einem meter 20 ein
stromlinienförmiger querschnitt
beschleunigt den wind unterhalb des
fahrbahn trägers und erzeugt so einen
abtrieb abgerundete kanten sollen zudem
die aerodynamik verbessern
die ingenieure testen zunächst ein
modell der brücke im windkanal bis sie
sich sicher sind dem viadukt von millau
wird selbst ein sturm mit
geschwindigkeiten von 205 kilometern pro
stunde nichts anhaben
gleich zum bau der golden gate bridge
hat man heute ein ganz anderes
verständnis für die aerodynamik effekte
rund um eine brücke
drei meter hohe windabweiser schützen
außerdem die autos auf der fahrbahn
all das ein voller erfolg die brücke
musste noch nie wegen sturm schließen
die golden gate bridge hat schon ein
paar mal in ihrer über 80-jährigen
geschichte wegen orkanen stundenweise
dicht gemacht
beide brücken sind technische
meisterwerke auch was die sicherheit
angeht
[Musik]
es folgt die bauphase
wie schwer ist es solche giganten zu
errichten
[Musik]
wie nahezu jedes große bauprojekt hat
auch die golden gate bridge schon vor
dem ersten spatenstich mit widerständen
zu kämpfen
denn die landschaft rund um die meerenge
golden gate gilt als unberührt und
wunderschön viele glauben dass eine
derart große brücke die idylle zerstören
würde
hinzu kommen wirtschaftliche aspekte
ortsansässige
speditionsfirmen fürchten die brücke
könnte den schiffsverkehr
beeinträchtigen und so ihre geschäfte
ruinieren
auch die fährbetreiber sorgen sich ums
geschäft in mehr als 2000
gerichtsverfahren versuchen sie
lukratives monopol zu verteidigen und
selbst die us-navy wehrt sich gegen die
brücke ihre angst sie könnte bei einem
bombenangriff kollabieren und so die
hafeneinfahrt versperren
trotz musste überzeugungsarbeit leisten
er ist überall hingefahren und hat für
seine brücke geworben
gross hat erfolg 1930 ist die
genehmigung für eine brücke über die
golden gate meerenge da aber das nächste
problem bahnt sich an denn im jahr zuvor
kollabiert die wall street und mit dem
börsencrash beginnt die große depression
die finanzkrise erfasst das ganze land
und investoren springen ab kaum einer
hat in dieser situation noch den mut in
ein mammut bauwerk wie die golden gate
bridge zu investieren
ich kann mich an kein projekt erinnern
bei dem so viele abgesprungen sind und
dass dennoch realisiert wurde die
einwohner san franciscos haben selbst in
der krise gesagt wir bezahlen die kosten
für die brücke einfach selbst
die menschen verwenden ihren besitz als
sicherheit für eine insgesamt 35
millionen us dollar anleihe genauso hoch
wie die geplanten baukosten
umgerechnet heute um die 600 millionen
nur dank dieser aktion beginnen
schließlich nach 20 jahren planung im
jahr 1933 die bauarbeiten
trotz aller widerstände schreibt die
golden gate bridge schließlich
geschichte
rund 100 jahre später kämpfen auch die
architekten des viadukt von millau mit
ähnlichen problemen die anwohner
protestieren denn viele glauben die
gigantische dimensionen der brücke würde
die traumhafte landschaft verschandeln
manila viele anwohner hätten fosters
pläne für größenwahnsinnig
außerdem kritisieren viele die hohen
baukosten und wieder steckt die welt
kurz vor baubeginn in einer tiefen
finanzkrise
erst sorgen sich finanziers um den
sogenannten millennium bug auch right to
play genannt viele glauben unsere
computersysteme könnten durch den
jahrtausendwechsel zusammenbrechen dann
platzt im märz 2000 die dotcom-blase
zahlreiche geheime tech unternehmen
können ihre gewinn erwartungen nicht
erfüllen weltweit brachen die kurse ein
[Applaus]
doch politiker in der französischen
hauptstadt paris geben nicht auf sie
beauftragen die firmengruppe mit dem bau
der staat hat schließlich die nachkommen
gustav s beauftragt dem ingenieur des
legendären eiffelturms des viadukts mio
zu bauen
am 14 dezember 2001 ist es endlich so
weit der bau beginnt
das übernimmt die baukosten in höhe von
400 millionen euro
im gegenzug erhält die firmengruppe das
recht 75 jahre lang maut zu erheben
[Musik]
ob heute oder vor rund 100 jahren
beide gigantischen projekte stoßen auf
massive widerstände sie zu bewältigen
dauert jahre doch letztendlich ist der
grundstein gelegt um sich wenig später
der nächsten großen herausforderung zu
stellen dem bau der brückenpfeiler die
jeweils höchsten ihrer zeit
bei der golden gate bridge macht der
nördliche turm wenig probleme denn hier
ist das wasser flach
auf der südseite ist der bau des turms
kompliziert denn die wassertiefe beträgt
33 meter
[Musik]
wer nie zuvor ist ein brückenpfeiler so
ins meer gebaut wurden noch dazu in
dieser tiefe für viele kleine das
einfach nur verrückt
die lösung sie setzen unter wasserbomben
ein die den felsigen meeresboden glätten
anschließend installieren taucher einen
stahlrahmen um beton auszugießen der
sogenannte fender ist so groß wie ein
fußballfeld und seine zwölf meter dicken
mauern ermöglichen nicht nur die
fundament legen sie sollen die pfeiler
später auch vor gefahren jedweder art
schützen
[Musik]
die taucher müssen gegen starke
strömungen ankämpfen
wegen der strömungen können die taucher
nur während des seitenwechsels viermal
täglich für 20 minuten abtauchen
für druckluft ausgleich bleibt kaum zeit
im schlimmsten fall drohen atemnot
innere blutungen und bewusstlosigkeit
schließlich steht der fender sobald
dieser leergepumpt ist kann das
fundament gelegt werden
[Musik]
die fundament legung für den super zwei
jahre gedauert verrückt wenn man bedenkt
dass der gesamte bau nur vier jahre
gebraucht hat
der restliche unterbau ist
vergleichsweise einfach aus
vorgefertigten stählernen zellen und
rund einer million nieten entstehen
innerhalb von sechs monaten die höchsten
brückenpfeiler ihrer zeit
der bau des süd pfeilers der golden gate
bridge zählt zu den schwierigsten
fundament legen der geschichte
ist der unterbau für die brücke von mio
noch komplizierter
keiner der sieben pfeiler steht im
wasser geschweige denn im meer
dafür ist der kalkstein boden hier porös
und voller hohlräume die gefahr eines
erdrutsches ist sehr hoch
hierfür ein stabiles fundament zu sorgen
ist keine leichte aufgabe
damit die pfeiler genug stabilität haben
steht jeder von ihnen auf 4 bohrpfählen
mit einer tiefe von bis zu 15 metern des
bei trotz des schlechten bodens hat es
gerade mal sechs monate gedauert um
sämtliche fundamente zu bauen im
vergleich zur golden gate bridge wo
alles unter wasser stattfinden musste
man sie wesentlich schneller doch das
fundament ist nicht das einzige problem
der ingenieure sorgen bereitet ihnen vor
allem der besondere aufbau der pfeiler
am grund haben die rautenförmigen pfeile
einen querschnitt von 200 quadratmetern
nach oben hin schrumpfen sie nach und
nach auf eine fläche von circa 30
quadratmetern
entsprechend sind die beton
verschalungen äußerst komplex und müssen
sich stets neu an die vorgegebene form
anpassen
[Musik]
alle vier meter musste die kletter
schalung angepasst und auf wenige
millimeter genau positioniert werden
denn jeder fehler muss an einem genau
festgelegten punkt enden hunderte meter
über dem grund die höhe der pfeiler
desto eher können fehler passieren
zur unterstützung nutzen die ingenieure
gps das global positioning system
wir alle kennen und verwenden diese
technik mit unseren handys und
navigationsgeräten um unseren standort
zu ermitteln das prinzip dahinter der
empfänger erhält signale von mindestens
vier satelliten aus der differenz der
signalwege berechnet das empfangsgerät
die genaue position
selbst kleinste bewegungen zum beispiel
durch temperaturschwankungen oder
erschütterungen können den bau gefährden
dasselbe projekt wäre 20 jahre zuvor
nicht möglich gewesen weil es die
technischen hilfsmittel noch nicht gab
nach 20 monaten atmen die ingenieure auf
der bau der bis dahin höchsten
brückenpfeiler ist vollendet
der bau der pfeiler ist bei beiden
projekten eine herausforderung die
erbauer der brücke von mio setzen auf
hightech die der golden gate bridge
riskieren sogar ihr leben
in runde drei geht es um den überbau
wie kompliziert war es dass brücken deck
mitsamt seinem truck system zu
installieren
bei der golden gate bridge werden dafür
vor allem gigantische kabel gebraucht
dabei betreten die brückenbauer neuland
die beiden hauptkabel sind mit 2300 32
metern die längsten kabel der welt und
mit einem durchmesser von 92 zentimetern
auch die dicksten ihr gewicht 12.000
tonnen
es ist damals unmöglich der schwere und
lange kabel über die mehr als 200 meter
hohen pylone zu ziehen die arbeiter
mussten sie sozusagen an ort und stelle
zusammenbauen
räder transportieren die einzelnen
drähte von anker blog zu anker blog dann
erst werden die einzel drähte zu einem
hauptkabel zusammengepresst
eine strapazierte arbeit denn jedes
kabel besteht aus über
27.000 einzel treten
dieses luft spinn verfahren machte
hängebrücken mit so enorm langen und
schweren truck sein überhaupt erst
möglich
die methode ist effizient sie
beschleunigt die arbeiten an der golden
gate bridge um ganze acht monate
so entsteht in atemberaubender
geschwindigkeit die damals längste
hängebrücke der welt
im 21 jahrhundert stehen die ingenieure
des viadukt von mio vor einer ähnlich
großen herausforderung wie installiert
man ein zweieinhalb kilometer langes
brücken deck mit einem gewicht von
36.000 tonnen und das in einer höhe von
245 metern
normalerweise wird das brücken weg von
den pylonen aus schrittweise in beide
richtungen montiert hier funktioniert es
nicht
allein die kraft des windes in dieser
höhe macht die montage in der luft
nahezu unmöglich
die baufirma es plant deshalb die
brücken deck elemente auf den beiden
anhöhen vor zu montieren und von dort
über die brückenpfeiler bis zur mitte zu
schieben
der vorschlag ist mutig in dieser
größenordnung hat das noch nie jemand
gewagt doch auch wenn es verrückt klingt
es scheint dennoch die einzige chance zu
sein das projekt zu vollenden
damit die brückenpfeiler dabei nicht
umfallen müssen sie die reibungskräfte
so gering wie möglich halten die
ingenieure installieren deshalb an
sämtlichen auflage punkten teflon
beschichtete teile dieses system gibt
dass brücken deck immer wieder an gibt
es in vier minuten 60 cm nach vorne und
senkt es dann ab
keiner konnte sicher sagen ob das
funktioniert im gegenteil viele
ingenieure bezweifelten dass es klappt
zunächst läuft alles reibungslos doch
nach sechs monaten tritt plötzlich ein
problem auf eines der kühlsysteme bricht
und das system blockiert das brücken
decke hängt ungesichert im wind
245 meter über dem erdboden
noch dazu zieht ein sturm auf man kann
sich kaum vorstellen was die
verantwortlichen ingenieure durchgemacht
haben
nach nervenaufreibenden stunden gelingt
es ihnen den gebrochenen keil am
nächsten morgen auszutauschen endlich
können sie das deck weiter schieben
doch erst am ende zeigt sich ob die
beiden teile auch wirklich perfekt
zusammenpassen
angesichts der gekrümmten fahrbahn und
des höhenunterschieds beider seiten ein
extremes wagnis
nach einem jahr und zwei monaten der
große moment die beiden teile des
brücken decks treffen aufeinander
und
sie passen
die erleichterung riesig gewesen sein
die abweichung betrug weniger als zwei
zentimeter und war damit im rahmen der
toleranz sie haben es tatsächlich
geschafft
die ingenieure des viadukts von mio
bewältigen die technische
meisterleistung mit bravour und die ist
tatsächlich deutlich komplexer als das
kabel spinnen bei der golden gate bridge
fazit in der kategorie beide brücken
hatten große hürden zu überwinden ob in
sachen genehmigung fundament oder
überbau
[Musik]
zum schluss geht es um die effizienz
wie schlagen sich die brücken in der
praxis
[Musik]
um 1930 leben in marin county nördlich
von san francisco
140.000 menschen viele von ihnen
arbeiten in der großen stadt jeden tag
überqueren sie mit der autofähre die
meerenge golden gate
wartezeiten von zwei bis drei stunden
sind keine seltenheit und auch am
wochenende stößt der fährbetrieb an
seine grenzen denn autos werden
zunehmend beliebter immer mehr menschen
aus san francisco unternehmen am
wochenende ausflüge in die einzigartige
landschaft
die golden gate bridge hat diese oase
den stadtbewohnern leicht zugänglich
gemacht
1937 nach vierjähriger bauzeit ist die
golden gate bridge fertig am 28 mai
punkt zwölf uhr mittags wird die brücke
für den verkehr geöffnet
[Musik]
32.000 autos rollen am ersten tag über
die neue brücke für die damalige zeit
eine gigantische zahl und der verkehr
nimmt zu
die golden gate bridge hatte massiven
einfluss auf die gesamte region
die einwohnerzahl von marin county hat
sich innerhalb von drei jahrzehnten
vervielfacht
heute fahren täglich rund
120.000 fahrzeuge über die golden gate
bridge auf sechs fahrspuren kommen die
reisenden und pendler schneller ans ziel
im jahr rund 40 millionen
um diesen andrang effizient zu steuern
besitzt die golden gate bridge die
sogenannte sippe maschinen sie
verschiebt je nach rush hour die
mittelleitplanke diese maßnahmen reichen
nicht das verkehrsproblem ist kaum
lösbar die brücke ist ausgelegt für 9000
autos pro stunde in der rushhour sind es
11.000 die vermutlich legendärste brücke
der welt hat für ein rasantes wachstum
gesorgt
verkehrstechnisch steht sie aber immer
öfter kurz vor dem kollaps
wie effizient ist das viadukt von millau
in frankreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vor der eröffnung 2004 quälen sich hier
alle fahrzeuge mühsam auf serpentinen
straßen ab unten im tal müssen sie auf
einer engen antiken brücke den fluss
tarn überqueren
die folge kilometerlange staus und
zahlreiche unfälle das kleine städtchen
mio wird bekannt für monster staus in
den ferien welt die autor oder 75 eine
wichtige verbindung nord und südeuropas
ist die unterbrochen im sommer kam es
regelmäßig zu den schlimmsten staus
europas
am 14 dezember 2004 eröffnet der
damalige staatspräsident jacques chirac
höchstpersönlich das viadukt von mio
französisch viadukte mio
zwar ist das verkehrsaufkommen kaum mit
dem in san francisco zu vergleichen im
durchschnitt überqueren nur circa 15.000
autos täglich die brücke von joh doch
zur hauptreisezeit können es bis zu
50.000 werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so skeptisch die menschen hier in der
region waren was die brücke betrifft so
sehr haben sie von ihr profitiert
wirtschaftlich ist die brücke ein erfolg
denn mit dem bau der brücke schnell die
besucherzahlen in der einst
strukturschwachen region in die höhe
beide brücken sind ein segen für ihre
region sie haben den verkehr
revolutioniert und die wirtschaft
angekurbelt die golden gate bridge kommt
allerdings immer mehr an ihre
belastungsgrenze
rücken sind nicht nur dafür da um von a
nach b zu kommen sie können auch zum
wahrzeichen ihrer region werden und sie
ziehen massen von besuchern an das gilt
sowohl für die golden gate bridge als
auch für das viadukt von mio
[Musik]
die bewohner von san francisco schließen
die golden gate bridge sofort ins herz
200.000 menschen strömen nach der
eröffnung am sogenannten pedestrian day
zu der brücke um das architektonische
wunder zu bestaunen
außer dem putsch die stadtverwaltung den
kultstatus der brücke sie lockt die
großen hollywoodstars
15 produktion erhalten günstige
konditionen hitchcocks vertigo planet
der affen star trek oder james bond kaum
ein setting kommt öfter in kinofilmen
war
das zieht auch touristen an rund zehn
millionen pro jahr wollen sich diese
aussicht nicht entgehen lassen inklusive
erinnerungsfoto
der kultstatus der golden gate bridge
ist seit über 80 jahren ungebrochen sie
ist das wahrzeichen san franciscos und
der gesamten westküste
und die wohl meistfotografierte brücke
der welt
[Applaus]
aber auch das viadukt von millau
besuchen inzwischen knapp eineinhalb
millionen menschen jährlich darunter
touristen architekten und brücken
enthusiasten
zu beginn hatten sogar zahlreiche fans
mitten auf der brücke um das bauwerk zu
bestaunen inzwischen ist das verboten
und auch frankreich prescht sein
beeindruckendes bauwerk wo es nur geht
die franzosen sind unglaublich stolz auf
ihre brücke und das auch zu recht sie
ist einer der spektakulärsten der welt
doch die ganz große bekanntheit über die
landesgrenzen hinweg bleibt ihr bislang
verwehrt
[Applaus]
natürlich hat eine brücke in diesem
ländlichen wenig besiedelten gebiet
schwierigere voraussetzungen zum
kultobjekt zu werden
auch wenn das beeindruckend designte
viadukt von millau durchaus punkten kann
in sachen kult ist die golden gate
bridge nicht zu schlagen sie kennt
einfach jeder
[Musik]
zeit für die allerletzte runde wie
nachhaltig sind die brücken gebaut
tonnen schwerer verkehr der ohne
unterbrechung über sie hinweg donnert
setzt der golden gate bridge genauso zu
wie sturmböen und feuchte salzhaltige
luft die folgen sind enorm
ein wartungsteam kämpft täglich gegen
rost und verschleiß selbst bei nebel
arbeiten sich die arbeiter mit pinsel
und farbe bis zu den 200 meter hohen
turm spitzen vor
beauty ob die schönheit der golden gate
bridge hat einen preis sie ist ein
wartungs monster der immerwährende nebel
und aggressive salz wasser setzen ihr zu
ihr stahl ist anders als bei später
gebauten brücken nicht vorbehandelt auch
das macht sie besonders anfällig
jährlich verpassen die arbeiter der
brücke um die 19.000 liter rostschutz
farbe
sollten doch mal stahlelemente oder
nieten rosten kommen sogenannte sky
cowboys zum einsatz stahlarbeiter die
die kaputten teile ersetzen es ist ein
brutaler job die stürme der nebel der
rutschige stahl dafür muss man gemacht
sein und die alternde brücke hat noch
weitere schwachstellen
kabel und hänger müssen regelmäßig neu
gestrafft werden aufgrund von
temperaturschwankungen und beanspruchung
verlieren sie nach und nach ihre
optimale spannung einmal in ihrer
80-jährigen geschichte tauscht das
drücken team die hänge seile sogar
komplett aus alles bei laufendem verkehr
die golden gate bridge ist zu
wartungsintensiv das immer wieder
stimmen laut werden man sollte sie doch
komplett umbauen
die golden gate bridge am leben zu
erhalten ist tatsächlich ein immenser
aufwand wie sieht das bei der brücke von
mio aus
der stahl ist schon mal kein problem
denn der ist intensiv vorbehandelt
zusätzlich sorgen luftentfeuchter dafür
dass rost hier kaum eine chance hat
bis heute ist jedes bauteil original
doch dafür gibt es einen anderen großen
nachteil den porösen kalkstein boden
die fundamente der brückenpfeiler müssen
ständig überwacht werden
das funktioniert mit hightech im
fundament sind zwölf glasfaser sensoren
die bewegungen im mikrometerbereich
wahrnehmen
gleichzeitig machen dehnungs messer an
der spitze bis zu 100 messungen pro
sekunde
[Musik]
technik allein reicht nicht ein
wartungsteam ist rund um die uhr im
einsatz
auf menschen kann man nicht verzichten
sie behalten wie bei der golden gate
bridge die spannung der kabel im auge
die beträgt zwischen 900 und 1200 tonnen
das team kontrolliert die
windverhältnisse alle 30 minuten genau
wie die temperatur des brückentags auch
die pfeiler überprüft es ständig auf
betonschäden
alles in allem ist moderne ikone aber so
konzipiert der sich der wartungsaufwand
in grenzen hält das viadukt von millau
ist so gebaut dass eine lebenszeit von
120 jahren garantiert ist und dabei
braucht sie viel weniger pflege als die
über 80-jährige golden gate bridge in
kalifornien
beide brücken entlasten den verkehr in
ihrer region enorm beide haben einen
kultstatus wobei die golden gate bridge
weltweit mehr fans hat doch dafür ist
sie auch deutlich wartungs anfälliger
knapp 70 jahre liegen zwischen dem bau
des viadukt von mio der längsten
schrägseilbrücke der welt
und der berühmtesten drücke der golden
gate bridge
[Musik]
ob in sachen design bau oder effizienz
beide ikonen zeugen vom pioniergeist der
ingenieure und sind wahrzeichen mit
wow-effekt
mit ihrer schönheit und der besonderen
lage faszinieren sie die menschen seit
dem tag ihrer eröffnung